this morning I had a chance to speak
with Speaker Boehner and I told them
what I've been saying publicly that I am
happy to talk with him and other
Republicans about anything having such a
conversation talks negotiations
shouldn't require hanging the threats of
a government shutdown or economic chaos
over the heads of the American people no
American president would deal with a
foreign leader like this most of you
would not deal with either co-workers or
business associates in this fashion and
we shouldn't be dealing this way here in
Washington there are enough reasonable
Republicans and Democrats in the house
who are willing to vote YES on a budget
that the Senate has already passed that
vote could take place today we're not
going to calm creditors until they see
Speaker Boehner call up a bill that
reopens the government and authorizes
the Secretary of Treasury to pay our
bills on time my message the world is
the United States always has paid its
bills and it will do so again but I
think they're not just looking at what I
say they're looking at what Congress
does and that ultimately is up to
Speaker Boehner i'm not going to breach
a basic principle that would weaken the
presidency change our democracy and do
great damage to ordinary people just in
order to go along with what the House
Republicans are talking about